foreign
and talked to Gerard what's up Jared how
we doing man
pretty good Dr John uh long time
listener first time caller yes that's a
that's I always hope people will say
that and you did so that's awesome you
made my day what's up glad you're back
man don't worry
um yeah thanks for taking my call so um
basically I'm just trying to get some
some guidance and uh maybe some next
steps on how to put a 20-year friendship
to bed and let go oh wow
almost always that's uh somebody did a
thing what happened
oh they definitely did a thing
what is it man
all right so I guess I'll give you a
little bit of backstory
um I have a I mean he's my best friend
or was I guess I should say basically my
brother I mean 20 years is a long time
to have a friendship right hey call that
up that is
a this sounds like the beginning to a
Dawson's Creek episode I'm not gonna lie
and I'm super excited about it two
um yeah that's a brother dude 20 years
side by side that's a brother right yeah
definitely so anyway
um I met my fiancee uh about five years
ago we got engaged last year uh our
wedding's actually coming up in 16 days
at this point very cool congratulations
man thanks thank you um anyway so
um my best friend and my fiance they
didn't always see eye to eye
um you know it was uh I think a little
bit of you know
vying for my attention at some at some
points you know and uh so anyway they
over the past few years have really
gotten close
um
you know him and his wife we barbecue
together we hang out all the time you
know we're it's the crew right and uh
and so they finally gotten to a point my
fiance and and him where you know they
were they were tied everything was going
well and uh
he actually uh his him and his wife's
for your wedding anniversary just passed
and he thought it would be cool to kind
of repropos to her because they kind of
eloped the first time
and uh he asked me to host it at my
house you know kind of a surprise Shin
dig free proposal and I was like of
course brother like I got you I'll have
everybody over we'll keep a surprise
yada yada
um
so that all went fine it was nice they
stayed over afterwards too you know
barbecue hang out we were having some
celebratory drinks and what have you and
uh
I ended up me and his wife ended up
um you know
going to bed it was late and I'm not
together right not together no I was
gonna clarify that all right yeah just I
held my breath there for a second
yeah I was hoping you were calling to
tell me how bad your friend was because
you slept with his wife okay good so
that didn't happen so you and his wife
went to bed separately I feel like I
know all this story's headed then what
yep he uh he made a pass on my fiance
what does that mean
he uh he tried to kiss her okay
and when they were and it
they were you know out obviously by
themselves talking together and uh it's
funny because he it wasn't just like a
like a drunk in though I'm gonna lean in
and make a path like he physically
grabbed her face and pulled it toward
him to try to kiss her
and uh
she pushed him away and dodged it and
was like you know what the heck are you
doing and uh he hopefully she's a
stronger language than that she
definitely did I'm trying to keep it
radio very cool you're a good guy it
helps a sound engineer not have to make
so many edits so good for you yeah
exactly okay uh she
and dodged it so nothing happened but
then he went in and tried again
the kisser a second time and I mean she
let him have it my fiance is a strong
woman it's part of the reason I'm with
her she she doesn't take any crap you
know so she kind of let him have it and
he
uh
he tried to
make her the reason for his choice in
that instance saying that you know
earlier in the night she had
complimented him and told him he looked
nice and he actually wrote us he was
supposed to be the best man in my
wedding by the way so there's another
there's another wrench to throw in it
but he opted out of that role he's
self-selected out right
uh definitely he wrote you a letter
no he had written us a song that he was
going to play at our wedding to your
wife
I mean it's hard to say at this point
looking back you know but anyway it was
it was obvious it was obviously like an
emotional song we were all emotional and
so you know he she like had her hand on
his shoulder like while we were
listening to the song and so he used
that as
uh his invitation I guess to uh to make
a pass that hurt when I was asleep uh
and and then then took it one step
further and was like you know uh you've
just been so nice to me lately and uh I
don't know what it is it's just your
eyes and here's the kicker that he said
that I I can't get past John is he's
like I just wanted to know what it would
feel like
and uh
what an idiot well I mean I was that
another word it's just idiot and so let
me let me I want to clarify something
just because I know in these moments
after 20 years like just the rage
there's the upset and then and then if
you're honest 100 honest
there's been some quiet in the back of
your mind did she like lead on like was
she did she play any part of this
because my that's my brother right and
oh yeah let me be super clear I'm
thinking right now and they're I'm sure
they're okay they don't listen to this
show I assure you I'm thinking of two of
my best friends on the planet John and
Todd and their wives Jennifer and
Melissa
um
and I'm thinking of my wife and those
two guys
I would trust my wife to go on vacation
with those two guys
I would I have sought out hey Melissa
how do I look in this shirt and she
would say you look great man you like
really look handsome
and not one time or Jennifer hey can I
come crash at y'all's house while I'm in
town for school absolutely there's
always a bed in my home like right so
it's some of the kindest most hospitable
and she I'll walk in and she's like oh
my gosh you've been working out and like
yeah never once is that an invitation to
hook up right 100 100 because you know
why because those two men are my
brothers and that makes them my sisters
and my personal sister who I don't talk
a lot about she's she's mine like it's
real close to my chest
um if she tells me I look good it's like
I look handsome you look good
except for my wife that's like the next
best good feeling when my sister says
that and not one time do I think oh well
I just want to know what it's like to
kiss you that's just stupid man what an
idiot what an idiot what a violation man
so it was a complete violation so um so
what's your question because yeah what's
your question well I'm struggling
because you know obviously like you said
my first instinct was I'm gonna kill him
right yeah uh and then and then the the
devastation and the herd set in yeah um
and just the complete you know betrayal
of it all and uh I've just been really
struggling with it I've been anxious
about it uh have you talked to him have
you talked to him I have I haven't
talked to him since uh I mean I
confronted him once uh when he decided
to show up at my house when I finally
found out uh and I told him you know you
just need to leave like you're not
welcome here like I I can't talk to you
right now you know
um and I just told him like I need some
space man like you know I will reach out
when uh when I'm ready to talk
so so you know I took about a week and
then I finally decided like okay I might
be at a point where I can like type
something out and send it to him you
know and uh because initially he sent me
a text message saying that he felt bad
and and you know
he doesn't remember much and then he
said and then he said he said if what's
being said actually happens and I'm more
apologetic than I can express and I'm
like that's just a cop-out dude you know
yeah so not only is he is he um
did he make a pass that you're that
you're about to be a wife uh twice
physically right and again like you you
mentioned it's not like there was like
this closeness and then like it just
kind of happened he grabbed her face
right he made a physical like he took
hold of possession of tried to take
possession of her body right that's
that's that's that's layer that's a
layer deeper
um then he doesn't have the character to
look in the eye and say dude I screwed
up
in the deepest way possible right he's
like uh if if uh if yeah I don't have
any time for it man
look at you get your question man get
your question I talked too long on these
sometimes no you're good you're good uh
I just I'm trying to figure out uh how
number one if I should even allow him to
speak his piece in this and number two
like how do I get closure from this man
because like obviously he's out of the
wedding like that's 100 but more than
that like I am at this point feel like
I'm mourning a 20-year friendship and I
just I'm not sure you are if I need I'm
not sure if I need to give him a chance
to talk it out or if I just need to find
closure on my own with this
um
I'm I'm gonna say something's probably
not going to be very popular on the
internet and I I don't care
um I think that's person specific
yeah I don't know the closure is right
for everybody
I know me and I'm thinking back to the
friends I have that are 20-year friends
I personally I feel like I would have to
know what were you doing
um that only can happen if someone's
willing to take ownership of what they
did
right right which is not yeah and so at
that point I I got nothing to say man
because not only did you did you
go after after my wife
but
um you think I'm dumb and you're calling
me a liar
all right and you're calling my wife a
liar yeah so uh I mean at every level
there's violations of trust there
um I do like I got to tell you so for me
I hold those type of friendships so
sacred they're holy to me right they are
so um important that I would have to
hear somebody out that but but that is
not instructive wisdom for everybody
that's just me
yeah I think in a lot of cases
um
that would be it would be it
'd be it and here's here's I always go
back to the heaping burning coals right
um
I don't think it would be something
where I'm gonna puff up and act like a
Instagram hero and try to be all tough I
don't think that's the thing
um I think the conversation to be had is
I need you to hear me say
um you violated my trust at the chorus
level you try to take possession of my
wife's body
I need you to hear hear me say you've
opted out a friendship with me and my
family
so this is it I wish you the best
and um this is over
and I know it sounds dramatic and that
sounds like like a like a romantic
breakup but I think after 20 years
there's something to be heard he needs
to hear the resolve for you not the you
because then you you pull yourself down
to his level right of this like right
you you turn into a high school kid that
can't control himself that's I'm not
gonna do that I'm not gonna stoop to
your level I'm gonna let you know as an
adult
you opted out of this and it breaks my
heart man you're my best friend
and bye right and and I think there's
something to that
um but also
you and everybody listening that is not
for everybody
there are some better things just dude
I'm not even going to um I've gotten bit
doing that like going back to the well
right getting back someone's ugly to me
and I reach back out to them and just
digs the hole deeper for me
um I really try to go the extra mile on
some of those things uh and it's it's
often not worth it but for me I would
feel the need to say I'm putting a
period into this I'm ending this not you
what you did doesn't end things I am and
uh I wish you the best
and I'm gonna move on with my life you
don't see I mean that that'd be the way
I handle it
I mean that's what I've been leaning
towards honestly especially because like
we mostly communicate over social and
that week after it happened that I was
finally calm enough to write something
out to him I went on to our platform
that we normally talk on and I'm like oh
we're not friends so then I started
digging and he removed me from all
social media yeah well I haven't got a
chance to talk to him tell me what I
need to know bro get out of that world
that's that's like that's like he broke
up with you in Legend of Zelda that's
not real right so I I wouldn't go
through like did you is he following me
is he did he like my post get out of
that plan dude you can drive yourself
insane be a grown man
um and sit down and talk to him or uh
talk to him on the phone like I don't I
don't feel like talking to you I don't
want to come see you or um or come
whatever but
um
uh I I that's gonna be that right so I
yeah I don't have some big magical thing
I wish I did
um I could tell you that I think the
friendship's over I don't know that you
move past that but I also think that um
you get to decide everybody listening
you get to decide how this the period
into the sentence if the period is I'm
not ever having that conversation again
great great
hold your head up high don't be a child
about it it's over somebody violated you
at your core and I'll also say this
um we are often
um
you know the old saying goes like he
stabbed me in the back
we are often not prepared when people we
love and care about stab Us in the face
and it happens
they look you in the eye and they lie to
you they look you in the eye and deeply
betray you and what you said right
mourning and grieving that's what it is
it's a death of something because what
we had was Brotherhood what we had was
I will be there at 2 A.M
what it what we had was you can always
stay at my house your wife can always
stay at my house
and that's over now
and that hurts man it's not cool to say
it and it's like I don't want to wait
it's Dawson's creaky I get that it hurts
man it hurts and so there's gonna have
to be a season of grieving that and
mourning that and then you Jared
you're gonna have to go find new 20-year
friends because you can't do life
without them and you can't be like oh
that guy hurt me the one time I'm out no
dude that's what that guy did and I'll
tell you I got some close close close
Buddies
um very close
and I'm not worried for one second about
them making a pass in my life I'm just
not
and so
um those friends are out there there's
more of those friends than
what your idiot buddy did and I'm
heartbroken for you man 20-year
friendships take 20 years to develop
that's hard it's a lot of investment and
time and love and I hate that you got
burned with it man
I hate that
but I can't make the call for you but I
I do want to know how you decided to
handle it holler back at me and let me
know let me know how it goes and by the
way don't communicate electronically be
an adult No Electronic back and forth
that world's over call them on the phone
or go meet him for coffee